foreign
[Music]
cast number seven my name is John
Striker Meyer welcome to
this podcast courtesy of Jocko will link
Productions
the story comes from command and control
South
July 16 1968
and we're looking at this from a
perspective of the helicopter Pilots the
crew members for a little different
perspective on sog
so on this date on the July the 16th
there had been a 28-man hatchet force on
the ground in Cambodia
since
um for about eight days so on this day
the
that element comes into contact at about
the same time a six-man Recon team gets
inserted and of course there's some
weather questions and uh we're going to
read from one of the gunmen the gun crew
members who on that day were flying
and he said now reading from the book
here secret Green Beret Commandos in
Cambodia
by attorney Lieutenant Colonel Fred
Lindsay who was a commander at CCS for a
period of time during 1771.
we're quoting here
Pat McMullen wrote I remember we got the
team in and that's the Recon team and
the guns stayed on station if needed
shortly after they went in they made
contact
that same time the typhoon blew in
our slicks were grounded at Kwon Loy
so we were all those guys had
so here we came
there was no hesitation
those were our guys down there
and they needed help
the guns
were the only ones still in the air
the guys in the ground
we're taking wounded in action and they
needed to be evacuated
since we were the only ones there
Lieutenant Sigmund said he we would come
get them
he said to fire up all of our ammo
we fired all of our door gun ammo and
all the Rockets
but both minis jammed
those are the miniguns Sigmund told us
to use the door guns to fire it up this
worked well until both of the operating
Springs fell apart in a million pieces
and jammed both of them
we couldn't even get them apart
the lieutenant then had us break it into
three neep round pieces and throw it out
the door
until he felt we were light enough
we then went in and picked up six or
eight little people and headed I think
to Quan Loi
could have been Dua Tien
I know for sure that was the rough
roughest ride I ever been in in a
helicopter pilot
we did everything except go upside down
another uh Crew Chief and that was
Richard Ty Furbies
he recalled we had the teams in trouble
it was really nasty weather
we went anyway
we left Dal tiang and couldn't get back
Captain Sigmund first lieutenant Neil
first lieutenant Hyman
chief warrant tigerdine and chief
warrant Satterfield and Captain wildell
hope I didn't leave anybody out we're
all awarded medals for their flying
abilities
what do I remember is that we were
really in thick soup
I just sat back and trusted the pilots
what else could I do
as I remember
only one or two of them actually had an
instrument ticket at the time
oh yeah and we came back through that
weather
with the teams on board
so today I want to introduce our guests
who flew with Lieutenant Neal
and this was with the 195th helicopter
unit like to introduce
Don Haas today Don welcome to the show
welcome till glad to be here thank you
and I think that is one of the classic
missions
and again like a lot would just say just
another day in song
but
um this is an opportunity for us to look
at it from the aviators perspective and
uh
had the award citation where they went
into the details about what that
operation was not only did he get the
Recon team out but then at the same time
uh the six-man distraction the 28-man
reported heavy contact and numerous
casualties the air commander and other
supporting aircraft were now completely
weathered in
so this is just another day and this is
Cambodia
so talk to a little bit about the um
your tour Duty which began October of
1967. uh yeah I uh joined the army in
July in fact my official date is July
3rd 1966 and went to basic training up
at Fort Lewis Washington and after basic
training went to Fort Eustis Virginia to
go through 67 and 20 which is the MOs
for the helicopter repairman on a UE
helicopter AKA crew chief AKA crew chief
the the crew chief is the one of the
door Gunners and he's the flight
mechanic that flies with the aircraft uh
the thinking that if the mechanic's
going to work on the aircraft if he were
to fly with it he might do a little bit
better job I've been in what he was
doing because it could direct his life
directly so in other words anything went
wrong they said hey fix it
yeah more of a fell in the sky you'd be
blamed not the pilots no the crew chief
exactly and and if if uh you know we
screwed up and we crashed in a in a ball
of fire someplace you know it was our
fault
and you know most 19 year old kids don't
want to do that
do you know particularly today but back
then 1968 you're on the job exactly so
uh you're with Lieutenant Neal that day
and then
um take us back to a little bit of the
weather condition I mean
he kind of glanced over the fact that a
typhoon hit suddenly
but the team's in contact and everybody
those gunships went out there and
whereabouts were you all on that day
yeah we were at uh Quan Lloyd which was
a launch site uh CCS also had another
launch site at Dao tiang Juan Loy was up
closer to the border and so it was used
uh Dao tiang was about uh
15 20 clicks South of the Border right
so at that time there were three
separate commands for Saga at that time
CCS was South which was Batman to it and
then you had the launch sites where the
Recon teams were Hatchet force would go
out then you all would pick them up get
brief for a mission before launching for
the Target then cartoon or CCC up in two
core then i-core with CCN and they had
several launch sites up there so getting
back to CCS which by the way Fred
Lindsay's book is the biggest most
thorough book on command and control
South produced today correct and it's
just really an outstanding he goes from
the beginning all the way through to
even at the end which is over 500 pages
of uh work that he put into this effort
yeah uh Fred Lindsay's uh book is really
designed to be a scholar study of ccs
and their operations and what they did
and he covers it in order for the story
to get into the book there had to be a
uh a metal citation awarded right and as
you know till in SOG probably only 20 or
30 percent of the missions that were
performed uh actually got citations
because of the classified nature of our
work it was just not talked about we
tried to keep a very low profile indeed
and so because the sog operations were
top secret any helicopter asset that
came in was the gunship slick cranes
whatever it was they all came in but
they understand you can't talk about
this yeah for at least 20 years right in
fact uh what was your briefing like on
that when uh in the end of May yeah we
May 68. yeah the end of May 68 we uh
went back to work for SOG we'd worked
for him the month of April and then we
took some time off uh primarily because
of the May offense even uh Saigon we
were down uh defendants the second yeah
it's called The Many tatters of uh
officially it's the May offensive but uh
unofficially it's mini chat that's what
we call it by golly that's our history
we're sticking to it yeah
really but it wasn't like you're going
down to just another day in the sunshine
go out to the beach you're down there
defending troops and positions against
another Invasion from the Communists
that were trying to take over Saigon
yeah there was a major major offensive
they did get uh uh several uh units
inside Saigon and the ninth Infantry
Division had to uh kick them out
basically and uh then uh
after that the May of 68 probably the
20th we were in part of a a hundred ship
combat assault and basically we took a
division of troops and were put a
blocking force on the Cambodian border
and then the ninth division pushed the
troops out of out of the Saigon and we
tried to am hammer and anvil on on a
Cambodian border when they returned
after that mission then we went back
Colonel Drake
requested our uh was the oh I see at
that time yeah Colonel Drake guy is the
officer in charge he was the officer in
charge of Sigma and sigma and Omega were
joined to form ccs and password because
68 we still had family to it which was
fob5 and then we had the whole noctow
which is f of B6 which I was a little
familiar with and met Colonel Drake
there in November of 68. yeah right
after I came home yes indeed you left
and I had to pick up the pieces
thereafter no exactly
uh so anyway when we went back to them
our uh commanding officer the 195th
decided that we should have sterilized
camouflage helicopters like the 20th SOS
did up at bammy to it which was the Air
Force unit yes and the Air Force Heelys
were uh painted a camouflage three color
scheme in the Air Force tradition and uh
so we got a bunch of AK-47s from the
sigma people and we traded one AK-47 for
a paint job
with the Air Force and we ended up
getting all 31 of our helicopters
painted you know we used to have slimber
trades up north where we either given
AK-47 captured from the enemy sure or a
bloodied flag and a communist flag for
500 Stakes the same kind of trading some
of those those flags have big blood on
them or chicken
one or the other or somebody cut
themselves fixing their web gear and
they bleed on it yeah but good enough
for the Air Force or 500 Stakes are in
your case a whole paint job yeah so we
so at that time we were completely
sterile we had no U.S markings on the
helicopters and we took all of our our
dog tags off and all of our name tags
off our uniform in fact most of us went
to the tiger striped uniforms at that
time with no markings and we carried no
uh identification of any kind of
paperwork and we had to sign a
non-disclosure statement that we
wouldn't talk about what we were doing
uh in in wherever we went indeed to have
a time limit on that or just uh don't
talk it didn't it didn't have a time
limit it was forever right
and we were
[Music]
um
we were instructed that built we
couldn't have any uh Air Force Air cover
no attack air could cover Us in Vietnam
the only thing we could use was our own
indigenous thunder chicken gunships so
again this is in the Cambodian AO which
is also known as Daniel Boone at the
time and what we're talking about here
is if it if our units came into contact
whereas in Laos we had A1 skyraiders
Phantom jets that could be it might take
a while but they would eventually get
there to respond and at CCS none of that
was available it was strictly slicks
with whatever guns helicopter gunships
were attached that's what you're talking
about here correct the 195th and then
what was the chicken Thunder for the gun
yeah our uh our uh our the company uh
call sign and Logo was Sky chief for the
195th Assault Helicopter Company the
first platoon uh they were Snoopy in the
Red Baron and they had oh
Snoopy on on his doghouse and what a
scarf yeah with some with the scarf and
some Red Baron bullet holes in it like
cool cartoon yes and then the second
platoon was the Ghost Riders and that
was the platoon that I was in and and
then the gun platoon was the Thunder
chickens and the Thunder chickens got
their name kind of interesting when we
were at Fort Carson we would drink
Thunderbird wine and you could buy
Thunderbird wine for about 25 cents yeah
I was about to gallon or less 79 cents a
gallon and it wasn't good is it true
that you could use it for gasoline if
you ran out of gas I think so I think so
it was it was so bad that we would mix
seven up with it and
the the the mixture of Thunderbird wine
and seven up was nicknamed thunder
chicken
so when we got to Vietnam it was time to
you know develop a picture
yeah so so you know the kids in the in
the you know thunder chicken well let's
do thunder chicken so they designed this
rooster with rockets under its wings
right and uh they became the Thunder
chickens and uh uh actually had a very
valorous uh career in the Vietnam War uh
they were instrumental in Saving long
been and and uh Saigon and the Tet
Offensive in 1968. WoW along with
running SOG missions yeah and then of
course their uh their SOG missions in
fact uh now were you there for any of
that uh yeah it was 68 so you're yeah
you're modestly just saying this all
happened oh and by the way I was there
yeah yeah I was I was there I was uh
became Mr modesty yeah defending uh uh
long been yeah in fact when Ted happened
uh four days prior so Ted just for our
first time viewers would be at the end
of January of 68 February they had a
massive attack throughout the South
Vietnam by the communist forces NVA Viet
Cong they thought they could rise and if
the population would rally behind them
but they didn't and Americans won and
our allies one heavy major battle and
part of that was thanks to our air cover
and at long been you're talking about an
a camp that was there or the city or
both yeah the long band uh was a large
logistical base camp uh just North about
17 miles north of Saigon and about four
or five miles east of the Air Force Base
of Benoit and um so we had uh General uh
Whalen had believed the intelligence the
Recon teams and German Whalen was he was
the uh Westmoreland second in command
and he was in charge of the three-core
area
uh south of the southern part of Vietnam
right so at that time we had icor which
was North right on the DMZ come South to
court which was cartoon three-quarter
Saigon long Ben four core was the Delta
Delta South and and just exactly flat
and ugly with lots of water right and so
uh we were put on Red Alert 48 before
and uh I never heard that before no
kidding yeah yeah and uh you know I had
uh wrote a letter home to my parents
saying what does it mean when you've
been in country for four months and the
Army gives you your weapon out of the
lot Conex container and 80 rounds of
ammunition and all your web gear and
then Ted happened they didn't hear from
me for about three or four weeks and all
they saw was the news accounts wondering
what the hell happened oh my God
yeah we were uh so I was in at the time
I was in maintenance working the night
unscheduled maintenance team and we got
off about 11 30 at night and then we go
to the mess hall and eat what was our
breakfast and then hit the rack and we
were in Iraq about two in the morning we
heard uh rocket mortar rounds coming
into the long been base so we all rolled
out of the out of the tent and we're in
this big deep irrigation ditch and uh
laying there in our first combat just
scared shitless you know oh yeah and uh
you got the 122's coming out yeah and
those are the long missiles they're a
huge huge explosive device
um in fact people know of them now as
katusha rockets and that's what the uh
uh uh NBA use yeah what the NBA is and
it's what the uh Hamas is launching into
Israel pretty much and those Rockets I
mean we were told they could go through
10 inches of sandbags before they'd
explode they're just a god-awful yeah
and they they're piercing armor and they
did a tremendous amount of damage
absolutely
huge rockets and and uh so anyway
the executive officer comes up and he
goes I want six volunteers and he goes
you you you and you or them
and so for volunteering yeah so he took
us and we didn't even have any
Constantino wire on our perimeter and
off of our flight line we went out into
a jungle for about half a mile less than
half a mile and then there was long been
ammo dump was just a huge ammo storage
facility with underground bunkers with
with all of the artillery shells and Air
Force bombs and ammunition everything in
it and uh so we went down on the
perimeter and we had these uh about
three or four sandbag High c-shaped
bunker fighting positions that we were
put in with an M60 machine gun
and uh so I was uh laying there on my
M60 and had my my Gunner with me to feed
me ammo and you know we were all set
there were three of us per per bunker
position basically a fighting position
wasn't even really a bunker yeah and uh
and all of a sudden out in front of us
about uh maybe 150 yards I see this
gunship flying and pretty soon he turns
on his Landing light
and uh starts shooting with his minigun
into my horror a line of traces go up in
front of the the uh gunship and it's
Charlie
yeah trying to shoot him down and it
what I found out later was is that was
the the Vietnamese Barber that was the
cut hair for the 117th Assault
Helicopter Company and the 195th and he
was leading the sapper Team into the uh
pilot tents that he was gonna do a
zapper attack on the on the pilot
and uh
luckily and I found this out later uh
the 117th had a lieutenant Mitchum in it
and Lieutenant Mitchum was Prior Special
Forces and then he went to flight school
and became a helicopter pilot and he was
stationed at uh uh the 117th was right
across the road from us and they shared
the flight line with us in mess hall and
he had some friends down at honoktau
which is where Sigma was 46. yeah you've
been there oh yeah a little while yeah
and uh anyway he uh did didn't want to
carry a 38 which is what the Army issue
uh weapon for a pilot was and so they
took him into their arms locker and and
let him pick out what he wanted and he
picked out a grease gun
so a 45 caliber grease gun yeah yeah
yeah it's a M1A or yeah it's a virus
when he opened bolt yeah Hang on Sloopy
yeah and fire is a 40 45 caliber
pistol round so anyway when the mortar
started coming in he goes to the
perimeter immediately and he's there and
by now the flare ship had shown up and
in a flare he sees these people in The
Wire and so he lit them all up killed
all nine of them and when they went out
to get the bodies at Sunrise why it was
our company Barber and he was leading
the sappers in to to attack the berry
and you know had he not been there had
he not been prior military trained and
you know knew to go to the wire when
incoming came in you know there's no
telling what would have happened wow no
kidding and uh so you guys made it
through that night then so we did make
it through that night but the next day
we had snipers dug in on her perimeter
and they were shooting at us and they
kept us pinned down for probably three
or four days anytime you'd get up on a
work deck on top of the helicopter you'd
be shot at I can't tell you would try to
you were talking to me earlier about how
one of the key things with the
helicopter crew chief has to do is every
day get the grease removed from the top
where the propellers come into the
helicopter because otherwise it'd be too
much grit and so you had to do that and
whenever you go up to do a routine
maintenance like that yeah they'd be
taking Pockets out of this and keep us
on the ground so in between would you
take any or they're doing any uh slick
activity going out to pick up troops
drop people off or supporting gunships
not much the gun the gun teams were
inactivity the Thunder chickens they
were quite active through the whole time
I mean they were flying uh 15 16 18 hour
days wow in the defense and one thing uh
when we were at uh we were at song Bay
support and sigma up there and Aura Mega
one of the two yeah uh
they brought our gunships back when uh
when they knew the assault was happening
and on their way back about three in the
morning just north of long bin uh and on
the 199th light infantry became
perimeter they caught about 400 NBA in
the open coming to assault us from the
north and they just had a fish in a
barrel shooting time and just uh you
know afforded that attack it never
happened
and they how they happen to be in the
air that's just seemed very they were
just the luck of the draw they were
flying home to to support Saigon and uh
they just happened to fly by and noticed
all these people running around down
there and you know they knew they
weren't Americans because uh yeah they
didn't have American Uniforms on wow
they could tell that at three o'clock in
the morning yeah of course in Saigon and
Cambodia majority of Cambodia unless you
got to the north it was much more flat
terrain than what was uh we're aware of
like in layoffs with the mountains and
everything else yeah and the engineers
had cleared all of the area north of us
for a hundred yards or so out from the
199th perimeter so that you know they
didn't have the vegetation to conceal
themselves in right then you also had
the acamp locked in that was in nearby
too correct that was about 70 miles
north of us right on the Cambodian
border because they had a major Siege
there also yes and uh just for just a
little quick sidebar we knew the medic
who was there and they were under siege
for three or four days and after the
fourth day of the battle they're all
almost out of ammo and in the morning
through the haze they could see 3 000
NVA lineup they're going to overrun the
a camp and they were able to get through
to specter
killed him just wiped out three thousand
those floors would have been wiped out
oh yeah and that was just you know there
was all over that that happened
um there was uh right across the highway
one from long bin there was a little
village
and it was called the widows Village or
the orphans Village and it's where the
widows of the South Vietnamese Army that
were killed in battle lived and the NBA
and and VC had coming in and they took
over their their Village and they dug
bunkers inside their houses and they
were gonna assault the long bin post
across the highway from the West the
same time those guys to the north were
gonna Assault It same time that the
sapper were going to be blowing up all
of the pilots whoa and uh
the one of the commanders of the 11th
calf were there with their
apcs and he started as soon as he heard
the mortars and Rockets come in he
started going up the highway and going
towards this Village and he had some of
his guys Dismount and they were walking
up the road and you looked up the road
and there was a y in the dirt road and
he noticed there was a gun in placement
there and he could tell it was not a Ma
deuce 50 caliber machine gun but that it
was a Russian 51 caliber machine gun
and so he and his his cab unit took it
under Fire and those guys never got out
of their bunkers in the house to assault
us from the west and I learned later at
one of the reunions one of our guys
drove the hooch maids and and people
that worked on base for us home and they
were from that Village and usually when
they drop them off they'd say well we'll
see you tomorrow and they dropped them
off the night before tat and they said
goodbye
because they knew the VC were going to
attack they knew they didn't dare say
anything about it and uh they figured we
weren't going to survive the night wow
and but just through the luck of God and
some uh
Vigilant GIS uh their plans didn't come
to fruition indeed so then it gets back
to that mission in July that when we
opened up the show with talking about
um a typhoon coming in and the gun ships
go out fire up all the ammo make us get
rid as much weight as possible to pick
up a Recon team that has wounded they
get them out at the same time that 28
man hatch of force is getting hammered
and there's also gun runs and slicks
going up to get them right and uh the
30-man hatch of force we could carry
about six people per slick so you're
looking at five slicks required to do
that and then the Slick to get the
six-man Recon team and then there were
four guns that went along with that so
bring that down a little bit for your
side your pile is Lieutenant Neal yes
and the co-pilot is
um I don't really rotate through they
rotated uh what you cared about was your
pilot yeah and Lieutenant Neal was the
company instructor pilot so any new
pilot that came in the con country would
fly with him or if a pilot been in
country a while and wanted to you know
was close to becoming promoted to a
aircraft Commander which is a pilot in
charge then they would fly with
Lieutenant Neal and he'd run them
through their prep Paces so they pretty
much rotated all the time but what about
your fellow door gunner would that
rotate also or would you have somebody
you knew and loved over there no I had
the same door gunner that the whole time
and a man by the name Ed Krause and Ed
was to my way of speaking he was the
best gunner in Vietnam I mean he
we he was uh
really worked well with me and lots of
times the Gunner and crew chief would
would work together so
when we would work on the helicopter
we'd work on the helicopter together you
know he'd have so you train him up a
little bit yeah what you learned in crew
chief school yeah and he knew the
difference between a half inch wrench
and a 7 16 to hand me tools and you'd
hand me the right size safety wire and
and you know just be a helper so did he
volunteer to make your helicopter make
your helicopter one of the most polished
brightest so the colonel Drake would
want to fly in that lead bird yes he did
uh in fact uh and then I would help him
with the guns and sure we had uh the M60
uh we had a habit of the only time we
cleaned it was when the rate of fire
slowed down and that told us when the
rate of fire slowed down that told us
that the gas Port was getting plugged up
and we needed to take it down because
every time we tore it completely down
and cleaned it the first time we fired
it it would jam
really yeah and so what we did was every
day we'd take the silicone bolt grease
and we'd just give it a new shot of Bolt
grease keep the bolt low magic lotion
huh yeah you about yeah yeah yeah real
for him yeah a little dabble do you yeah
so uh you know we we did that we another
thing we did was we doubled the uh gas
piston return spring and that bumped the
M60 cycle rate of fire from about 550
rounds a minute to 600 rounds a minute
so we'd fire a little bit faster so we
can also delineate at that time this is
before the Cobra gunships arrived so as
a slick you would be the passenger
carriers you would go in to pick up the
teams and the gunships would support you
and I think that you know we always talk
about this kind of quickly from being on
the ground but like oh yeah we called
him helicopters they did some gun runs
the stick would come and pick us up we
go home but there's a lot more strategy
involved like so if you have a team in
contact
what would be the general working
principle there particularly if you're
in Cambodia
and that's all you have is just you and
your gunships you got to get the team
out what would be the tactic the general
approach to that Target so basically the
the way the tax freak works and I know
you know this but uh we would have four
slicks orbiting at altitude away from
two to three thousand five that altitude
would have been three thousand what we
called out of effective small so 8K
rounds would bounce off at that yeah
they they might reach that far but they
were going to be pretty spread out and
they weren't going to hit you many times
lower energy too you know or yeah they
might bounce off of a hard hard yeah
yeah something like a transmission or
something and uh so they would be in
orbit we would have a Forward Air
controller which was usually in contact
with the team and had them spotted on
the ground and then uh sometimes we
would have Colonel Drake at 5 000 feet
be in the command in control controlling
the whole operation would he'd be a
helicopter or he'd go to he'd be in a
helicopter also okay yeah he'd be in one
of the 195th helicopters so on a Recon
team extraction we might have five slick
helicopters involved and four gunships
involved
two teams right and staggered so if one
had to go rearm and refuel we still had
one on stage station
and then uh
one ship would go down and pick the team
up the others three orbitings were to uh
if the ship got shot down in the LZ then
they were a Chase ship and one of those
ships is what the chase medic would fly
on when they had a Chase medic which was
to go down and render and so with
Cambodia because it was flat you're
usually able on the first run to pick up
a whole six-man team you didn't have to
worry about elevation and things like
that
for weight factors well yeah we you know
we kept the we had a uh the Lycoming 13
engine so we had a couple more hundred
horsepower so what model used for that
because I know the Air Force at that
when did the Air Force get the end
models that were more powerful allegedly
well actually uh the deal on that is
the air force uh their Huey's we have
Lycoming engines the Army had like
homing engines Air Force didn't want to
use the Lycoming engine because their
h-53s used General Electric engines all
right and the General Electric engines
were a little bit stronger and so they
made the Air Force Huey's had General
Electric engines on them and I think
they had about
1475 horsepower we had 1300 horsepower
so the first time I rode in one of those
that was a little bit it seemed a little
quicker yeah and they they uh had the B
model chassis the shorter chassis and
but they could still pick up six men
yeah on the on the B model they had a
thousand horsepower engine and they were
could only pick up about four Americans
and then when they went to the gunship
they put the uh uh the bigger engine on
them and a wider rotor blade and they
could carry the the gun load that's a
lot of technical stuff yeah but it's
also critical mass because that that's
your entire ground support it's what
makes it work yeah and uh I I think we
were because of commanding officer had
worked with special forces in the early
days at Fort Bragg in the early 60s and
then supported them in 65 on his first
tour in Vietnam come and we had the
stronger engines I think we were pretty
much developed to work for the special
forces in Saab when we went to Vietnam
we had uh the stronger engine one thing
the stronger engine would do is we could
hover at altitude
and hover yeah so you could and the
hovering and altitude capability gave
you the ability to throw the McGuire rig
ropes down right and do what we call the
string extractions sure and uh
so uh the the earlier B models with the
thousand and even 1100 horsepower engine
didn't have the power to hover at
altitude they had to get on their their
ground cover off the ground about five
feet and then go forward and go into
translation transitional lift and the
Forward Air Speed Give Them Enough lift
to fly wow getting back to that old
thing that you know here we just beats
the the air into submissions the only
reason applies
indeed and so generally if you what
you're talking about is the ropes if
there's a team on the ground you there's
not enough room for an LZ the helicopter
comes drop the ropes and how long were
the ropes at 150. they could they could
be anywhere from
150 100 150 depending on the train we
were operating on the Special Forces
rigor that tied them in the helicopter
would you know would have the the
shorter the better uh but if you're in a
150 foot trees you want to be able to
get to the ground if that causes some
problems and then for for lower
insertions we had uh a ladder and uh
most of the time we first started we
used the Rope ladders which were really
difficult to climb but uh
Norm Downey when he was in Project Delta
developed a ladder that was cables and
it had aluminum rungs on it and was a
lot more stable and it worked a lot
better because you know it's almost
impossible to climb a row platter and
and there they'd climb up on the ladder
and then they would snap a D-Link into a
rung on the ladder and then they would
get her into the steel cable could be a
more narrow yeah exactly
wow and then with that so so we get back
to the distraction Concepts so teams in
contact
they would get the gun runs and you all
would hover and one of the things you
observed which I never heard before
talking about a hammerhead maneuver
where the gunships would do Hammerheads
could you talk about that a little bit
because I never thought about that I
mean we was we need a helicopter gunship
being they would be there but not
thinking about the tactics there was a
couple of tactics one was a racetrack
and the idea was is the gunship team one
on each side of the switch would fly in
a circular oval like a race track and
the idea was is that when one gunship
finished the run and was pulling out
then the other gunship would be pulling
in at the other end of the racetrack and
put fire underneath them and protect
their belly until they got turned out
and then when that next one went in the
second one would be back around to that
spot and so they were just simply going
around an oval track covering each other
then another uh formation was what was
called the hammer head
and the helicopter would come in and it
would do a gun run and then it would do
what's called a cyclic climb and that's
where you tip the rotor blade back as
far as you can the helicopter would
climb real fast for a certain point and
then the air speed it bleed off well on
a hammer head they would do the cyclic
climb out and then they would do a pedal
turn turn back around and dive back in
on the Target and the gunship would be
doing that at different angles and so
one would come in and they would still
have one would be coming in protecting
the other one when it's in its cyclic
climb then when the the second ship went
in and the first one would do a hammer
head and basically just go up like this
rotate and come back down kind of like a
hammer head and your carnival ride whoa
and that really gives you good
continuity for fire support for the team
on the ground then that would go on for
a period and then the selects would come
in right behind it yeah pick up the team
and be gone basically the idea is
sometimes we would be coming in while
all that's going on you know they they
would be laying fire on both sides of us
and we'd come in between the fire and
the idea is we wanted to swoop in and
get the team on well the enemy had their
heads down from all the firing they were
seeing and that doesn't happen overnight
it takes a little bit of practice and
make that kind of a Precision maneuver
particularly when you're working
gunships with a team on the ground in
contact with the Enemy on top of it it
does and one thing I was going to say
about the hammer head uh maneuver
maneuver is is it up north where you
were where there were mountains it was
hard it wasn't effective to do that down
south where it was a lot flatter
territory we could get away with that
because we didn't have the mountain
obstacles
well it's not saying they couldn't do it
up there it just you know complicated
things so in getting back to that July
day the 16th we were talking about the
gunships making a run where were you
involved in that day so uh I was uh at
we were at Quan Lloyd I was on stripped
standby and and Lieutenant Neal was my
pilot and we got the call that the teams
were in trouble and so uh Lieutenant
Neal said I'll go get the the six-man
team and the other slicks with the will
follow the guns in and go pick the
hatchet Force up and we uh took off and
just uh you know blinding rainstorm I
mean it was I I had no idea an aircraft
could I didn't even think Ducks could
fly in this kind of weather it was so
bad and we're talking about whether
other to the extent it could have been
called a typhoon or a typhoon level of
rain which means it could be horizontal
rain yeah yeah terrible horizontal
raining and we had the monsoons there
but uh you know if they described it as
a typhoon if you go back and attack
weather records there probably was a
typhoon we were quite a bit Inland so
the hurricane forces would be more
prevalent on the coast but but you still
have the high winds that uh you know the
South and the Lower East Coast gets when
a hurricane comes in because I mean
going back to a citation from that era
major Ellie a United States Air Force
Ford air controller he managed to locate
that six-man team they were surrounded
he then vectored two guns means two
gunships to thunder chickens and two
slicks into the area and directed the
entire operation first lieutenant Neil
flew formation on the two gunships as
they Place suppressive fire
throughout the entire pickup site
and that did that almost record time the
team was extracted under intense heavy
fire
first lieutenant Niels aircraft
sustained three direct hits from enemy
fire
the entire flight assisted each other
and flying through the withering weather
and eventually managed to land safely at
Doyle tiang we called it Dao tiang Dao
tiang okay yeah thank you under
instrument conditions
at the same time the sex man distraction
the 28-man
reported heavy contact again they
suffered numerous casualties
their commission the air Mission
commander and all supporting aircraft
were now completely weathered in at Quan
Loi Captain Sigmund took complete
Command of the entire situation called
two additional standby aircraft from Dal
tiang and proceeded to the Battle Zone
fully extended Captain Sigmund was
relieved on station by first lieutenant
Everson and he goes on to replacing
picking up the people and then they're
able to return and get back to base in
total darkness under extremely dangerous
instrument conditions
and I didn't even realize that you all
had any
um instrument capabilities at that time
this is 68 right yeah it was uh the only
uh uh instrument that we had was the uh
FM radio which is frequency module and
that's what the uh private Aviation
calls ADF right and it's the directional
finding and so
when the lieutenant segment I believe it
was him uh got to doubt Yang he turned
on his uh FM radio
and the other slick were able to home in
on that radio signal and fly to it and
that's how they found that Yang the
weather was so bad that uh you know you
couldn't fly in it unless you were
instrument rated and army Aviator you
know weren't instrument raided at that
time at least the you know the young
helicopter pilot
and so you just kind of glanced over you
had three direct hits from what uh they
were from AK-47 or an RPD uh I'm
guessing because there were 30 caliber
and uh two of them hit the tail boom
right behind me and uh one of them uh
the M60 has a pedestal Mount and there's
about a four or five inch tube that is
bolted onto the chassis and then a
pedestal comes off of that and one
that's where you mount your M60 on where
the M60 is mounted on so you could swing
it and one of the rounds had pierced
that cross member the tube and it went
through one wall and lodged in the
second wall and that second wall saved
it from hitting me whoa
so Lily it died ran out of energy inches
and root to you yeah it was just sitting
in your guts if it had been a 50 caliber
you know or armor pitching you know I'd
have been hit and you know I'd at least
had a purple heart if nothing else
not dead an extra ass yeah blown open by
a 50 calorie oh
and so uh uh there were other times your
aircraft took some some heavy hits also
and this is again going in or picking up
the troops in this case a lot of times
going into CCS Targets in Cambodia yes
in fact uh we got shot down one time and
uh Lieutenant Neil was flying again and
we took 28 hits and
if we'd have taken 27 and the one hadn't
hit the fuel control device we probably
would have flown out of it but the 28th
round hit our the engine fuel control
device and put it out of commission the
engine lot Fuel and quit and so
helicopters just can't get along without
some fuel they got to have they got to
have that horsepower
to make them beat the air enough so
it'll submit
but then so what elevation uh what was
your altitude
when you got hit and did you auto rotate
it we had we had uh just just inserted a
team and we were on the way out and on
the insertion they started receiving
fire and so they went into the tree line
we were on our way out when we were hit
we went down uh
the uh we another ship behind us sat
down right beside us we the pilot and
co-pilot jumped out I jumped out was
running over there my Gunner was running
over there and he got about halfway
there and he realized oh [ __ ] I'm
supposed to get the guns and so so he
came back got the m60s and uh
run back over and when he is he tells it
he received the air medal with a V
device for his actions that day but if
he tells it he says I was just scared
shitless he said I went and grabbed the
guns because I was supposed to and about
10 feet of ammunition came with me and
so you know I'm running back to the
pickup helicopter with this ammunition
trailer along behind me and they thought
I was meritoriously setting up a
perimeter and I know that's exactly what
he was doing he just yeah yeah down
playing it after the fact
and uh it took
two weeks for me to get the helicopter
back flying again and I would have done
it in probably about eight or nine days
but the fuel control device had to be
ordered from army channels and had to
come in from Depot in the United States
and took it a while to get there
if if we'd had something to trade for we
might have been able to trade one for
another unit you know traded to make A's
or something or something but you know a
lot of times when helicopters went down
on layoffs they would come back in
Napalm yeah if the radius out anything
technically in a Napalm or do a thermite
uh run on them but so here you're able
to send back a crane yeah went back and
picked up your wounded bird brought it
back so you could work on and then yeah
this in this case uh it was either just
inside
Cambodia or just just across the border
in Vietnam anyway it was such that uh
the troops on the ground could secure
the aircraft and they could call a
Chinook helicopter in to hook onto it
and bring it bring it back to Plantation
where our base was and we could fix it
yeah it had you know all the plastic
Plexiglas chin Bubbles and everything
was all shot out of it is that right and
28 holes yeah and those that's on an
insertion so the mission was instantly
compromised yeah okay
yeah I mean the area we operated in was
uh you know it was a free fire zone it
was it was the NBA Charlie's territory
you know so anytime we went in we could
we could get uh have a hot LG was that
near the area where Roy Benavides had
his uh moment and uh with clashing with
the NVA on the LZ in early May of 68.
yeah it would have been within uh 10
miles or so that's a whole kilometers
yeah real close yeah very close because
here was just across the border uh in um
Cambodia probably uh from what I've seen
from the maps that they've got in uh
Colonel Lynch's book uh you know he was
uh just not too far about four or five
kilometers from where uh uh Jerry Mad
Dog driver was uh had his last mission
on the cops I mean that's April
1969. yeah and wow
you know so it was a definite very bad
neighborhood and uh you know we were we
were mortared every time we came back to
the fob
you know I mean it was well is that
right yeah they had murder teams as soon
as the helicopters would land why they
dropped a few more rounds on us but at
least not the 122s yes exactly like
welcome home here's a few mortars for
you yeah yeah there's kind of a funny
story in this book and uh doubting the
launch site on uh July 4th 1968 uh we
got word about uh 8 30 or 9 that the
Recon teams and patrols you know noticed
a lot of him and the activity and so
they were suspecting that there was
going to be an imminent attack on Dao
Jiang so they picked up the helicopters
and said let's take them back to Saigon
so we scrambled and flew back to Saigon
and
landed well uh that night uh Dow tiang
received five 500 at least incoming
mortar rounds and some rocket rounds and
after the barrage was over in the talk
the NBA came up on the radio and said
happy Fourth of July Americans
oh
talk about psyops huh yeah you know and
yeah our fourth of July at fob one we
had Intel reports about attack just to
because it was the Fourth of July they
wanted to make an impact and at midnight
we were so bored they just fired flares
for an hour or so and nothing happened
yeah well we just got dragged they
fought when they wanted to fight yeah
yeah I mean and they might look like
they're going to fight and never show
and then you know they did show
and they always try to do it would be to
their advantage they knew they would
plan things that way yeah
wow yeah so uh but anyway go help please
finish on that I was going to say uh
back to to the extraction yeah
um they uh
um would uh uh hit us anywhere and I was
going to say on the repairing the
helicopter uh the Plexiglas chin bubble
and windshield they have a screw that
holds them in about every inch all the
way around it so in a uh you know 30
inch two and a half foot by three foot
windshield you know you're looking at
probably
150 screws 120 32 something like that
and every one of those screws has a
self-locking knot no and it was before
the day a DeWalt cordless drills
so to replace the windshield why the
Gunner usually had to get inside and
hold the 3 8 inch wrench while the crew
chief was out
manual driving the
self-locking screw with a Phillips
screwdriver you really got screwed on
that detail yeah that was uh so you know
we always wanted to uh
you know when we were flying low level
yeah I want to make sure that the pilot
kept out of the trees and didn't you
know take any chin bubbles when we were
low leveling because that that's how low
level we flew right well yeah and then
also uh thinking about chin Bubbles and
level flying you you and I when we were
talking earlier mentioned
the cold
the the coolness of helicopter Pilots
I think you know we've heard stories
before choco podcast number 259 with
King B pilot Legend a major on and how
much they have the ice in their veins
and you're talking about the same thing
in Europe and particularly Lieutenant
Neal and how there is a day talk a
little bit about how there was blood in
the cockpit and the co-pilot thought he
had been shot
yes just another moment in time that
people never think about from inside the
helicopter please we were uh
on a mission and it was a hot LLC and uh
all of a sudden the the co-pilot who
just had a few a few hours in the
co-pilot he was relatively new maybe
whether the pilot copilot sit in the
American helicopters in the in the army
helicopters the aircraft Commander pilot
would be in the left seat the door
gunner would be in the left seat the
gunner in the right and the co-pilot
slash what we called the Peter pilot
right would be in the in the right seat
and the King bees were just the opposite
yeah the pilot was in the right seat and
the co-pilots on the left yeah that's
why I get so confused yeah thank you and
it is confusing yes and I I think there
were some other units that I've heard of
that maybe the Marines that followed the
king bees Uh custom of switching that
around but uh anyway
um so the the Peter pilot was flying and
all of a sudden he starts screaming I've
been shot I've been shot I've been shot
and they would received a couple of
rounds and uh I looked up in the cockpit
and there were blood splattered all over
the chin bubble and the windshield and
and so Lieutenant Neal just cool
communities that's okay I got it I got
it meaning he I got controlled here
please give me back the control take
your hands off I'm Gonna Fly the
aircraft and so uh you know this this
co-pilot and you're hearing on us on the
radio yeah we're on the internet you
look back you can see the blood in the
in the in the helicopter it's all over
the cockpit you know you can see blood
splattered everywhere and so you know
and I'm saying well we'll go to the
Medevac 93rd Medevac at long been and so
we fly down there and uh
get out and we sit down
Gene shuts the helicopter down and he
goes you know I was kind of hit in the
foot I better go in and get some
treatment myself and come to find out
the pilot wasn't hit he just got the
co-pilot wasn't it the co-pilot wasn't
hit he just got splattered with blood
and thought he was hit and it was
actually Gene's foot that got hit and
Gene not only did he get hit he flew the
helicopter back with a with a bullet
wound on his on his foot and operated
the control pedal landed and didn't get
excited didn't oh by the way I've been
shot in the foot but we'll just fly for
a while copal if you could just calm
down a little bit yeah yeah
oh my God you know it's just the way he
was and uh another time in fact the
reason that he liked to fly with me I
was flying with him one time and we were
inserting a hatchet force and uh it was
an artillery strike it hit the LZ before
we went in and so there were uh tree
snags in it and our place to to land
there's a tree snag right right
underneath the rotor blade and the
co-pilot was flying and he said we'll
lose to the road or RPM and which means
that we're losing power and and the
rotor was slowing down from 330
RPM and the slower the road would be the
lesson yeah so Gene says that's okay I
got it I got it and he said half he
unload the aircraft and we had a first
lieutenant Special Forces advisor on in
the right door in these cambodians and
so uh I go up and I tell the cambodians
to get off and they either didn't
understand plain English and or didn't
know what I was saying and we were about
12 14 feet off the ground so it was a
pretty good jump that's a real jump and
but I'm knowing full well if we hit that
snag that we're all dying right there in
the ball of fire yeah so I grab a hold
of one and Pitch him and next one I I
kind of shove and the other two they got
it got the message and jump and I looked
over and all the cambodians are gone and
that uh second Lieutenant sitting in the
door and I looked at him and I unplug
plug my mic cord and soon as he saw me
unplug the mic cord he went out
and so uh at 14 feet yeah yeah it might
have been 10 feet but it was it was
definitely uh you know you'd want to
have been closer can I just ask you a
question how often did you jump out of
your helicopter at 10 to 14 feet I never
did yeah no I know I never did and I
never recommended it indeed you wouldn't
but on this occasion in order to survive
it was it was a commander says
Lieutenant O'Neil said and I felt I mean
yeah I felt bad about it because I knew
you know poor guy breaking ankle down
there and the whole mission's
compromised now he's got to be Medevac
but if we were all dead you know that
was a compromise it gets a little messy
it might have cracked it might crack the
plexiglass you would have had to take it
off and yeah messed up your polish when
you crash they burn
all that jet fuel and those those uh uh
exotic titanium magnesium alloy metals
and everything when they get hot they
burn too oh and uh so yeah it's not a
thing didn't you have those uh
gas tanks that plug themselves if a bull
went through it or well that was the the
bottom two-thirds of it had a double
membrane but if it was the top third
they were only single membrane cut down
on weight
and so if the round was in the they had
a
two-sided and it had like a a tar in
between it the ideas around went through
it then the tar would fill the hole it
wasn't uh solvent soluble tar but it was
right you know would plug the hole and
and it wouldn't leak but if if the tanks
were full and around hit above that it
was going to spray fuel everywhere and
probably catch catch on fire
wow no so they they took me took the
aircraft back yeah and uh the engine
shop looked at it and they said yeah
it's it's uh Deep's a little adjustment
we got you fixed up
so they wrote The Red X off of the Red X
was an entry of the log book to mean the
aircraft was unflyable and needed a
maintenance attention and so they took
it up I took it up head and like I said
spent five months in maintenance so I
knew the the tech tech by the real well
yeah yeah and so we went up there and
he'd go 200 feet do a hover check engine
would bleed off I'd land I'd red exit
again
no kidding yeah because it was supposed
to do sure and they'd say well it's you
know they'd do something else to it it's
six now and so we go up it bleed our PM
I'd Red X again and I full well know
that when you're hovering around in the
jungle throwing the rope ladder out or
or a McGuire rig out to lift somebody
out you can't be losing RPM and not
hovering at altitude plus you have to be
able to lift Whatever Gets on right
after you've done it so I just kept
doing that and we went back and forth
for almost a week really and finally I
won and they sent sent me over to
bangtow the Depo maintenance and they
determined that the engine needed to be
replaced put a new engine in for me and
I got a nice couple days in one town
which was an RNR stand
and uh well after that
uh Gene Neal Lieutenant Neil being the
executive officer of the platoon had
decided that that's the crew chief I
want you know if he'll do that to make
sure this aircraft's flyable yeah he's
the one I want and so he uh uh because
he could pull rank he always assigned
himself to my aircraft and now we got
over a thousand hours together in all
different missions no kidding you know I
said a majority of those hours are going
across the fence and the kids
portion of them yeah but portion of them
were going either across the fin or with
the in-country uh Recon also you know
depending on where the activity was
uh
but uh yeah so that's uh you know a
little bit of background on what the
aviation oh yeah and you're talking
about Lieutenant Neal who
at some point he went to uh to bat for
you
and he said that he had to served with
you in Vietnam
from October 67 to 68
attached to the 195th Assault Helicopter
Company
at the plantation Army Field the
Republic of Vietnam and of course the
primary missionary was support for Mac V
saw
and he went on to say about you
Don was the flight pre-chief on uh-18
serial number 6616256
I had because I was Don's platoon leader
and an aircraft Commander by pulling
rank the opportunity to choose any
aircraft and crew I wanted
I chose Don
at 256 as the best of the 195th had and
I now believe at the subsequent tours
and all those years possibly the best
ever
in the Republic of Vietnam
together we flew over 1 000 combat hours
in support of Mac Visa
those previously classified missions
many and neighboring countries were
extremely dangerous and it seems as if
always under enemy fire
many missions were at night
and in poor weather adding to the stress
and eminent Danger
during infrequent downtime we flew
combat assaults and resupply missions
with the first Aviation Brigade for a
conventional U.S infantry units the 9th
the 25th the first and the 101st
divisions
Don never shied away
faulted Norman lined from his duties
he was an ideal Soldier representing and
protecting his country with Valor and
compassion
but more importantly
his technical skills and heroic Devotion
to his fellow soldiers were Paramount in
my survival and the survival of many
others that year
sign Lieutenant Eugene Neal Jr
that's quite a quite a Pat in the back
yeah and uh you know that story
exemplifies why he feels that way about
me you know I think and I might add that
you know most most Pilots flew in
Vietnam that had one true Chief they
flew with all the time felt that way
without is that right yeah they were
they were the best I mean they were they
were uh really top-notch people but you
know I did have a a German stubbornness
about me and uh spending five months in
in the maintenance company and and
knowing all the players uh you know I
was able to assert myself and you know a
younger less experienced crew chief
might not have won that battle and there
may have been a mission where they had
to get a SOG team out of the jungle on
ropes and they all side or you know
indeed we've had experiences like that
yeah the aircraft came down sure and had
to be extracted by someone else so you
know and and from the perspective of the
guys in the ground those are things they
never think about they just think get
the helicopter in here now yeah and
thank God you came hey and thank God
you're here now because we're getting
glowing bullets and then when you came
in
um did you get the special briefing or
was that automatically because you had
done so many SOG misses you understood
that when a soccer team came out of the
Jungle there would be Americans and
little people
yeah yeah that was just you know that
was just not an issue went with the
territory okay because sometimes up
north that became an issue but yeah that
was pretty much and then in in September
uh I worked with project Delta's
Roadrunner teams and that's right those
teams were three uh Vietnamese guys that
had NBA uniforms on NBA unit weapons and
NBA uh documentation for the units in
the area and they were called Roadrunner
because they were supposed to go out on
the trails run up and down the trails
and see who they run into and you had
experiences correct and yeah I inserted
them uh probably 30 times is that right
yeah well it wasn't what was your best
Road Runner Mission this one that kind
of stands out doesn't it well they're
yeah there's a couple yeah we got time
yeah this is Jocko's dime we got time
well and the thing about the roadrunners
is that they would come out of the
Jungle and you're sitting there in these
three NBA soldiers come out of the
jungle and so you have to remember who
you put in and get eye contact with that
same man right because if you don't you
better shoot him yeah you know I mean
that's a tough moment of decision there
yeah and I know you understand what I'm
talking about well yeah we didn't we in
the beginning we never had
people dressed like the roadrunners
later on our appointment was dressed
like an NBA but sometimes the young door
Gunners would come in and there'd be a
little bit of confusion there's some
tragic confusion but we never had that
with our team but in your case was there
a code or a signal or did he pick his
nose or something so you know it no
you're a Road Runner you dropped off two
days earlier
okay and and uh so yeah that was and
that's pretty Savvy to recognize these
guys yeah well and like I I was telling
you you know we we'd get we'd BS with
them when we were in downtime and and
they they spoke pretty good English and
so they could tell us what they were
doing and everything and to put them on
the helicopter we'd Park the helicopters
down out of the way off the end of the
runway and then they'd bring him down to
the helicopter in a uh three-quarter ton
truck under Poncho so nobody could see
yeah and uh to get them on but one
particular Mission they were running
down this Trail and they ran three of
them three of them yeah okay yeah just
three of them and they were running up
and down a trail and they ran across to
what would been a NBA lieutenant and an
NBA Sergeant would be a platoon leader
and a platoon sergeant and they started
talking to them in this particular unit
had just come down the Ho Chi Minh trail
from the north and they had just got
into to that part of Cambodia the cost
of an area about a week or two before
roadrunners ran into them
so the roadrunners talked to them got
the drop on them
arrested him took the weapons away from
him said you you know you're coming with
us
and so they called for an extraction so
we got the ship going out to instruct
them we got the other three helicopters
to chase aircrafted altitude and we'll
get on the here on the radio says uh oh
we got a couple more prisoners to better
send another aircraft and so uh we sent
another aircraft well when it was all
done
the
NBA young soldiers saw that their
platoon sergeant and platoon leader had
been captured by these guys and so they
give up they weren't going to stay down
in the jungle a thousand miles from home
by themselves and so they did that so
they did the church and come out and
surrender
and I think we ended up with somewhere 8
10 12 prisoners out of that those three
guys
yeah actually wow and they just had you
know I mean just I don't know how those
guys did it I mean they were Vietnamese
but what in North Vietnamese said it had
chuhoid themselves they they were they
knew how to talk about language because
there's a there's a language variation
between South and North Vietnam yeah and
uh I don't know you know they were
picked by the project Delta and and
vetted and trained by them and I don't
really know the details but yeah they
were probably originally from the north
and had at some time come South and then
decided to fight for the uh South
Vietnamese and uh were evidently pretty
damn good and they ended up with Delta
wow
all right well um we're at that point in
time here was there any other missions
like one will you go in and like get
more than 28 bullets during the pickup
of a Recon team or a moment in time and
during your 13 months uh in in country
with you and Lieutenant Neil raising
hell uh over there well there was one
particular time yeah please we went on a
uh
prisoner extraction during the tat
offensive guy by the name of Mike binge
who was a USA worker which is a
government agency that provides Aid and
he was bammy to it during the Tad
offensive and there were three
missionaries that were captured by the
NBA
and so uh about it was probably in the
May middle of June some place of 1968.
one of our Recon teams in Cambodia had
spotted them
where they were being held
and so we put together a mission to go
insert a uh uh 60 person 50 person
Hatchet Force Team to uh liberate them
from their pow account and so the day of
the the insertion came and we were going
to put them down at very first light and
so we flew over to Cambodia and we had
to have an LD big enough for 10 aircraft
because this was a big big surgeon wow
and so we're on short finals coming into
the lza where maybe a hundred feet off
the ground this early morning very first
light okay so first light yeah they have
their planning at night we had first
light yeah we had take we'd planned it
the day before we'd taken off before
light Before Sunrise to fly out there
and you know the idea what sure catch
him at first light so we come in we're
on your final and we look down and in
the trees on the tree line there's a
whole bunch of shelter temp like shelter
halves like pup tents and in front of
each tent there was stacked weapons in a
triangle of Staff yeah yeah and there
was all these little Vietnamese guys
running around in their underwear trying
to figure out what these helicopters are
doing and in their Camp
you know about a thousand NVA came in
and Biv whacked on the tree line of our
LG
and so we decided to abort the mission
and take off and and uh I don't know
they probably trying to still figure out
what happened uh what happened did they
ever get Mike binge uh thereafter or
they were never able to catch up with
him and capture him uh we put a Recon
team in about a week or two later and of
course they've moved him by then and
then after he was released after the war
uh you know we learned that they kept
moving them on and on into Cambodia and
finally he ended up in North Vietnam and
and was released with the rest of the
prisoners and Mike went on to uh teach
in the Sears school which is a survival
Escape in the vision School the pilots
and and of Legends operators go yes yeah
he actually developed the program for
and is an American Hero
serving as a usaid worker yes indeed
well any other last thoughts there from
your tour of Duty
um from after that then you do what when
you get out of the army you get out and
then go into civilian life and just do a
quick little thumbnail on that your
follow-up because you came out of high
school said I'm going to Vietnam or you
want to get it become yeah I had uh in
the fall of
1965 I had saw this Life
Magazine people about Yankee Papa 13 and
it was the U.S uh
helicopter Crew Chief and it was a story
about his job and duties and you know a
pilot that he'd watched get killed in an
LG and how that affected him and
everything and I thought that was with
the age 34 yeah with the the same
aircraft the king beef flew with yes sir
and
I was mechanically inclined like to
build cars and fix cars and so I thought
well working on helicopters to be cool
you know in aviation that that sounds
like a pretty good deal and I really
like that idea about you go to war you
drop the troops off and then you go home
yeah and then you know we always admired
that side of your MOS yeah yeah you know
the the part about having nothing to be
hide hide behind but an M60 yeah it was
a little different sided but I didn't
realize it you know the whole time
you're taking them in you're shooting
down did you ever hear what was the
there was always a rumor or a legend
saying the expected life expectancy of a
huey door gunner was how many minutes it
was yeah it was a rumor it wasn't true
wasn't true okay but but uh but first
ground pounds we heard that there were
so many door Gunners banged up or killed
that it was really a high rate it was uh
you know it was a high rate of uh uh
loss but I think uh there were like ten
thousand pilots and only 2 000 Pilots
were killed for vhpa records so about 20
percent chance of being killed but there
were a lot of missions there were a lot
of missions that didn't go anywhere near
the battlefield right you know flying
the media around and flying the brass
and the staff the ass and Brass yeah so
uh I uh read that article and uh I was
ready to go in the army then and my mom
said no you're 17 I'm not signing for
you you're going to graduate from high
school so you got edumacated so I got my
my edumacation in high school yeah and
uh July 3rd joined the army and I went
and went to helicopter school and I just
dreamed and to get my own helicopter and
be one of those crew chiefs indeed and
what day do you remember what data was
that you officially got your first bird
yeah it was it took a lot of her ringing
on my part
the maintenance people said we can't let
you go you're too valuable to us here we
gotta you know oh yeah they like the
bench turn or something yeah they they
needed us but uh finally it was about
15th of March uh they had an opening in
The Ghost Writer platoon and the platoon
sergeant had befriended me and so he
went to bat for me and they said okay
well you know we got some other people
we can train for that job now and so
they let me go and that's when I became
it and I tell you what I was just on
cloud nine and I tell you what it's just
been the highlight of my life indeed
nothing better than being a UE crew
chief no and then think of all the Recon
teams you all Lieutenant Neal saved
yeah when they're under Fire yeah
unfortunately a lot of them are my good
friends now indeed and that's uh we
should mention I think at this point
that um there is a veterans group called
the Special Operations Association found
that originally by SOG Recon men and uh
over the years we have our aviators that
are tasks everything from spad piles
we've invited to fast movers but they
have an attitude problem but the rotor
heads they're there and you now are have
been elected to the board of directors
serving a tour of Duty on the board of
directors
with the Special Operations Association
and then uh
on top of that
there's a video game out we can have
just a quick comment about the video
game when you've had a little taste of
this video game
and uh something a little different here
there's a for those of you Gamers out
there there's a brand new video game uh
it's part of the it's a cdlc for Arma 3
which is a military simulation game and
it's called SOG Prairie Fire and it's
about the saw Recon missions in Vietnam
and tilt's been an advisor on it for a
couple of years along with some other
Recon leaders yeah Jim shortened uh
Major General retired Ken boray is is
involved dick Thompson is uh and by the
way if you haven't seen Jocko podcast
number 204 205 particularly 205. that's
my after I watched that I felt like a
wimp I mean compared to dick and then
206 but yes I'm sorry yeah to get back
to the game to the game so uh
fortunately currently the the developers
were really interested in history in the
Vietnam War and they listened to Our
advice and they were at the virtual soar
reunion last fall during a presentation
and I noticed they didn't have any
Aviation advisors and so I told Rob
Graham the the leader I said you know I
got a lot of Aviation pictures and I can
give you some Aviation advice
and so we exchanged email addresses and
so I started giving them Aviation advice
so you became an advisor on top of it on
top of it too again I have to add I've
looked at some of these these
simulations of inside a UE from the
pilot seat and that is like I felt I was
right there well I went on
um I have a YouTube channel uh you do
you're a YouTube yeah under Hughes crew
chief it's the name okay if you if you
do a Google search one night say it
again one time so people can hear it
it's Hughes crew chief but if you do a
YouTube search 195th SOG most of the
videos will come up it'll pop and you
can you can watch them and including an
excellent historic one that you did a
few years ago for the 195th yeah yeah
that's really good they're all they're
all uh about the 195th and the sub
operators pictures and talking about SOG
ledge and Jerry Mad Dog Shriver and
because you had a little exposure to
Jerry and your time transporting SOG
Recon hatch enforcement in and out more
importantly picking them up and bringing
them home exactly
and so uh for the YouTube channel I
decided I needed a video editing
computer
so I started looking around and I
discovered that a gaming computer was
the same processor and graphics card and
everything as a video editing computer
was about five hundred dollars cheaper
about
so
I went to this computer Builder build
gaming computers and and got a computer
well it had steam on it which just seems
where you get all the video games or PCS
and so Rob was telling me well you know
you need to you know put the game on I
said well I do have Steam and so I was
communicating with him one day and he
said you know Arma 3 is on sale for 7.49
now right now and I said well I got it I
mean I could 749 that's a glass of beer
so I went and bought it and so then he
and their advisors got me hooked up with
the song Prairie Fire beta yeah and uh I
had it has a boot camp tutorial so I
went and learned how to walk and how to
bring your gun up and down and shoot I
said you know if you're gonna if you
want if you can walk you know we'll keep
you alive and these are all the
developers yeah yeah sure so I get the
game well before I want to go out with
him I want to practice and one of the
sog missions is called the bright light
Mission and that's where a SOG Recon
team goes and rescues the down
helicopter pilot and so we got a down
helicopter pilot so I'm out your single
player and and I I did it twice the
first time I uh I got killed a hundred
times before I got you know 500 yards
yeah yeah well to my ego at least it's a
video game
and but the second time I got all the
way to the helicopter
and so I decided single-handedly I'm
going to Salt the helicopter
and that didn't work out well and and
then Rob tells me he said yeah that the
bright bright lights for any of those
Recon missions are hard to do singles
player by yourself
so they said come on with us we'll we'll
run it with you so the team aspect so
the developers they heard that I'm going
to meet up with them and play and they
all want to play with a real vet
absolutely and so a real crew chief on
top yeah yeah a real sock guy that had
done this yeah and they you know they
were kind of excited that and they could
see why I picked the bright light
Mission first and seeing that we're
recovering an aviator indeed and so the
the game the scenario is is you have to
go to the to the uh helicopter to get to
the helicopter then you have to follow
the blood trail from the helicopter to a
communist NBA Village VC Village and
then you have to go down in a cave
complex
get you know
Overlook the uh pursuers right right and
in the cave and then you have to get the
pilot and then you have to you know
formulate a defense and then get the
heck out of there and uh
get extracted and of course the the uh
we put the team down here well I
couldn't see in the cave
and I later learned that my contrast was
too bright but
there's a ladder I'm supposed to climb
and I didn't even see it and supposed to
climb down to a lower level in the cave
so I just fell
so Rod decides well let's go outside
we'll defend The Outsiders because when
they come out of the tunnel with the
pilot the whole village is good so we
went outside got behind some rocks and
we got in about a 20-minute fire fight
and this is a five level complex cave
that the other guys are sneaking around
in shooting people and right you know
until they find the pilot and then they
got to bring him out you have to reload
your magazines too on like other video
games where they can fire a thousand
rounds yeah they could die a thousand
times and and uh you know I'm carrying a
RPD which has a uh it's a NBA machine
gun yeah and I had 100 round belt and
then I've got a saw 5 m79 oh is that
right a little Thumper yeah a little
something indeed and I got some advice
on how to get up for this and uh and so
we're in this hellacious fighter fight I
mean we got
three sides are around us and and uh
just you know shooting out like crazy
finally they come out with the pilot and
then we got a BT and it's a prairie fire
and of course lines you wrote the voice
actor is is yelling in our ears you know
as we're running and we got VC chasing
us and running gun battles and
authentic feel to it with the weapons
the gunfire and the jungle setting and
it pays homage to SOG and and the
aviators that were part of all that
absolutely and so we get up and we get
up on top of Hamburger Hill which is in
the game and that's our extractor point
so we gotta we gotta get in a uh a bomb
crater and defend the LZ and so we've
got air strikes going on they got tack
air and everything going in and around
us and you know we're in another five or
ten minute gun battle just like a real
song team would be until we get it
quieted down and then a helicopter comes
in and Lieutenant Neal's flying yeah I
don't know I think Don was but it was a
candy hey I I did on the helicopter and
we're all kind of talking going back and
I go I'm never doing that again
and of course several of the developers
had read some of the song books and
yearbooks and that the team died would
say you know they come out and they go
I'm never doing that again and then they
get back have a couple of beers get
bored and they're out there again indeed
the beat goes on but it uh it definitely
historically is very accurate uh the
Artistry and everything and the
helicopters and everything is is just
top-notch and uh you know I think it's
uh well done uh I think you've watched a
couple of streams uh chilled out I did
yeah it's really impressive and uh I'm
not a gamer but what I've seen I really
like and uh once we get settled we're
still moving getting settled into the
new home and uh are four acres in
Tennessee we're going to uh I'll be
spending more time with my my uh my
stepson really likes it and a few other
people I've talked to have looked at it
including our techie Tom the tech
our mystery man he liked it also well I
think that uh even if you don't have
time to play the game and you're not a
gamer I mean I've never I've never I
mean Solitaire on window Solitaire is my
computer game and I haven't played it
for 20 years and but I
uh watch my grandson glow growing up
play video games and uh now he's working
doesn't have plus time to play video
games but I twice a week there we go
guys all right any other last thoughts
sir
no sir in a pleasant time and uh well
likewise he likes to give that a little
bit of an insight into life of a crew
chief I hope sir I've given people a
little bit of what what went on behind
the scenes of just uh insertion and
extraction indeed you know well
um we're at that time where um we want
to
say our thanks to all veterans out there
men like Don Haas who fought for the
values of our country truly an American
hero one of our many that fought in the
secret War
to those of you out there on the front
lines today we thank you for fighting
all for our ideals for our country and
for our freedoms we also thank police
law enforcement border patrol the Secret
Service paramedics dispatchers
Corrections Officers
anyone out there helping our country be
a better country and thanks to all that
we can live so we live in safety and we
want to thank the Army Navy Marine Corps
Air Force Coast Guard and yes I guess we
now have the space for us for our
security today and for those who didn't
come home we salute you all
for without your sacrifice we would not
be a free country today
thank you for joining us until next time
and now for the PostScript after Saw
cast number seven myself and Tom the
mystery man my techie
um
that that time goes by fast it does it's
so quick to get a rotor head's
perspective on SOG missions your take on
this because this a lot of this is the
first time you've heard it yeah it's
definitely I mean it's definitely
different to hear
um from their point of view and in this
you know and what they have to go
through like oh yeah I mean
you know working with aircraft in in
stuff that I've done it's you know I've
talked to them but it's different
you're not them
I've been in a helicopter I've flown in
them yeah
but it's not the same and we jumped out
yeah roped out of them exactly pulled
out of jungles or you got pulled out of
somewhere but it's not it's not the same
it's it's just you know hearing their
point of view and seeing what they see
yeah you know it's just
going through
I mean going through that rainstorm just
that alone can you imagine
how do you fly like I you know uh I
talked to that one pilot that we were
talking about before that I met down at
Fort Benning and he uh
when he talked about it you know
comparing old aircraft you know the Huey
said you guys flew in versus the
Blackhawks and he said well that's not
flying you know Blackhawks that's not
flying oh you know because because it's
all computerized you know it's really
what his perspective yeah yeah sure he's
like Hugh he's flying he's like when you
fly with a map a compass
and just basically fly over the treetop
levels that's flying he's like you're
not you don't have computers tell you
where to go you just had a compass
because that line from Fred Lindsay's
book
we're quoting uh Sergeant Pat McMullen
how he remembered the team
and the gun state if needed well shortly
after they went in there was contact
and then he said they made contact at
that same time the typhoon blew in
typhoon
while the team's in contact our slicks
were grounded at Kwon Loy
Al so we were all those guys
had
so here we came yeah I mean here we came
in a typhoon these are gun ships that
aren't designed to pick up troops no so
they go out and spend a lot of ordinance
to make room and get ready to wait so
they could pick up people I mean that's
a huge sacrifice that's a huge risk I
mean just to just to do it and and to
have that you know like you said the ice
in the veins to be calm and Collective
and just do it you know I never got over
that no and I've seen Pilots like that
but it's like it's one of those things
you're like I don't understand do they
go to is that part of helicopter
training like how to get ice in your
veins
how to take out emotion yeah and then uh
hearing about the strings and everything
I think you've had I think you had a
tale of strings I know I know you had to
move it very long moving right along sir
thank you very much
I think you did yours upside down though
if I if I remember correctly
um
being cowboy
just hanging by your feet it's okay it's
good oh Lord yeah I mean the way they've
flown you know at Treetop level and map
of the Earth as they call it and it's
like you know flying that low knowing
you're I mean you're in range but you're
flying so fast that it's it's hard to
get you oh yeah you know it's quiet you
know you're so low to the ground but I
mean nothing but extraordinary you know
from a guy who's I want to be a
helicopter mechanic and now you're
flying missions for SOG and it's like oh
this is this is different yeah we can't
talk about it right now so finally he is
yeah and that's a little different
perspective to the whole War it
definitely is yeah and I loved it it was
great I mean the getting that other side
getting someone outside of it you know
you get that outside looking in kind of
view yeah still inside but it's a it's
that
the other component of what SOG was it
wasn't just
the Recon man it wasn't just all of that
it was it's the helicopter saviors and
that's I mean kudos to you to bringing
someone in from that side and Jocko and
you yeah for getting it to to arrange it
and have him come in and get that
different perspective because I think
that's
um you know we've talked about it before
it's it's that perspective that's not
covered you know there's certain parts
you're not covered you know that they
play in You Know instrumental role I
mean
without him where would you be oh yeah
you know I mean where would any of them
be yeah you know pilots and you know all
those guys that were willing to fly in
there and do that and then uh oh the one
thing I was gonna say is uh
I think uh blowing up the helicopter was
a dick Thompson story
he got chewed up for that one
if you want us to bring it back yeah
no we just they pumped it yeah yeah we
got the technical stuff out first then
we blew it and then just blew it up with
C4 I do remember that there happened to
be I think two at least one or two NBA
soldiers in inside the helicopter and he
put the charging so uh yeah so that
reminded me when I was talking about
that and then uh that's right the other
thing was uh so on the video game oh
yeah
played it for the first time this
morning really I can't say it went went
well I did it you got killed I did an
eldest son oh I figured I was gonna
start off I was like well this is easy
I'll do this one it's easy right I go in
I drop some stuff and I leave
yeah not so much I did it by myself I
didn't have a team so
I'm used to what other guys play I
haven't played video games since I was a
kid so yeah I'm no expert on video games
by any means don't let me fool you
because I think I shot my rifle more
times accidentally well I'm trying to
sneak around
because
yeah it didn't work I was using a
keyboard and a mouse pad but uh
I was basically sneaking up I'm like
okay I can hear him talking and I'm like
okay I can't see anybody so I'm like
well let me swing around and see what my
team's doing so
I do a 360.
there's nobody there but me and I'm like
oh oh this oh this is how this works
I'm alone
I'm The Loner doing an elder son with a
I had a I took the well I think it's a
M16 is what they have on there uh the
one I got was an M16 they didn't give me
a car 15 option the only game is Dick
Thompson's gun yeah and uh from the
pilot yeah and I took uh I took but I
took let's see I had eight 20 round
magazines which sucked only in 20 around
30. yeah so I had eight of those on my
kit and I had so then I brought 25 in my
I brought Claymores I brought uh
bouncing betties I brought frags I
loaded out as much as I could carry
and I'm going along and I'm doing good
and I'm like yeah I'm getting there you
know it's like I'm within like 400
meters of the Target because it gives
you a little yellow Beacon oh is that
right yeah yeah see at least you don't
get lost because I'd probably wander so
I get and I'm going
and uh all of a sudden I can hear them
and I'm like I was in I hear gunshots
I'm like oh
okay so where are they so I'm looking to
my right looking to my right I swing
back to my left and the guy comes around
tree and shoots me I'm like oh thank you
didn't even get a chance to shoot at him
just
like great you guys got a lot of ammo
now
so I definitely have to try it again
it's gonna take me a while to figure
that one out but I'll give it a shot
indeed
well any any other last minute thoughts
here no that's a i yeah incredible tales
and uh and again thank you for having me
here to listen to this uh I feel like
one of those guys that's you know proud
to sit here and listen to stuff and
store our history yeah and just
completely uh amazed about it every
every time I sit here and every time I
do this you know and so meanwhile we
have to pitch one more time oh yeah Fred
Lindsay's book The Secret Green Beret
Commandos in Cambodia it's available on
Amazon
Etc
stories abound today we only hit on one
story with some of the sidebars attached
to that but he goes through the entire
history of CCS for the early days and
then at the end when CCS was
decommissioned shut down the men the
Recon man then went North to CCN to uh
at Danang CCC cartoon and he documents
that as well as some of the awards and
decorations and as we first started
talking like Don said
um
the uh book is based off of citations so
any action happened was the citation
related which means there's a lot that
weren't yeah and Colonel Lindsay to his
credit put years into this book and uh
so it has everything from different
sides of the story including this one
that's why we picked it and we thank
Colonel Lindsay who's today in Indiana
and still uh working hard and cheering
us on as we move forward and so with
that we'll close out today and again we
thank uh all of our service members for
our freedoms from the Army Air Force
Navy Marine Corps Coast Guard yesterday
space force all out there looking out
for our country and even though some of
our leadership might not remember what
Memorial Day is about we do we pay
homage to those troops We Salute them
all and to all the front line personnel
and other law enforcement agencies
particularly the border patrol Homeland
Security that's under a great deal of
stress today
and we just continue to carry them in
our prayers and pray for our country
so we thank you for that and we thank
you for Jocko for the opportunity to
bring sogcast number seven to you today
and until next time we'll be lining up
some more which will include a Medal of
Honor recipient
until next time thank you for joining us
today
Al